l'odeur de chair en décomposition
imprègne la ville comme un brouillard
putride
les monceaux de cadavres empêchent
l'accès aux rues c'est comme si nous
étions à la veille du jour du jugement
d'affi
brûlé là
je vais vous donner un conseil faites
vos affaires est parti tant que vous
pouvez encore
je les croisais envie de toujours et se
comportait bizarrement je vous le dis il
n'y a qu'une seule explication possible
elle a fait un pacte avec le diable
si nous échappera pas essentielle
qu'est ce qui va marquer
ils vont essayer de briser c'est ce
qu'ils ont fait à nous tous
n'ayez pas peur mon enfant votre salut
est proche
[Musique]
il se passe des choses c'est elle qui ne
sont vraiment malades
[Musique]
hélas le diable en elle
ma volonté est plus forte que la mort
ces scores
avouez
[Musique]
personne n'est à l'abri
[Applaudissements]